thank you everyone for joining us
um now as you can imagine the fact that
i am speaking
to you at 5 30 p.m on the saturday
before christmas
having just chaired an emergency meeting
of my cabinet
and spoken to the leaders of the
opposition parties
suggests a serious situation and it also
suggests a situation
that necessitates action the information
that i
and my cabinet have received today about
the new variant
of the covered virus that has been
identified in the uk
suggests to me that we do now face a
very serious
situation it is in fact probably the
most serious
and potentially dangerous juncture we
have
faced since the start of the covert
pandemic
in february and march and that means we
have to
take this seriously and it means that we
have to
act accordingly and appropriately
now the upside although i appreciate
that given what i am about to set out to
you it may seem
inappropriate to be talking about
upsides but the upside
is that if we do act now and if we act
firmly now we can prevent that serious
situation
materializing and the advantage that we
have
in scotland unlike some other parts of
the uk
right now is that we still do have the
chance
to act on a preventative basis
so i want to set out clearly to you
today
what for scotland the current situation
is
i will also set out why in light of an
assessment of that situation
i consider that very firm preventative
action
is now necessary and i will outline
to you the action that the cabinet has
agreed
this afternoon to take now as i set out
in parliament earlier this week covert
cases in scotland
had been falling in recent weeks as a
result of the tough restrictions
that everybody has been living under but
in the most recent week
those cases had started to rise again in
parts of the country
it was as a result of that that a number
of local authorities
were put into tighter level three
restrictions and that took
effect yesterday and a number of others
a larger number of others
were required to stay in level three
restrictions however notwithstanding
that it is also the case that the
situation in scotland
right now at this moment in time is not
as severe as it is in other parts of the
uk
casey's pair hundred thousand of the
population in scotland are around
half the number that we currently see in
england
and around a third of the numbers being
experienced in wales
and our statistics today which of course
were published earlier on this afternoon
572 new cases representing four percent
of all tests carried out yesterday
suggests a broadly stable position
so all things being equal while we had
no room for complacency
we had hoped that we might get through
the next few weeks
at least in many parts of the country
without significantly more
severe restrictions being necessary
unfortunately as is so often the case
with this virus all things are not
proving to be equal
last week it was confirmed a new variant
of the virus had been
identified in the uk and on tuesday i
advised parliament that a small number
of cases
of that new strain had already been
identified in scotland
now over last night and today the
governments of the four nations across
the uk have received
further scientific briefing on the
impact
of this new strain the uk chief
scientific advisor
updated a four nations meeting that i
participated in this morning
and the chief medical officer who you'll
hear from shortly has updated the
scottish government cabinet this
afternoon
now firstly it's very important for me
to be clear
that at this stage there is no evidence
to suggest that this new strain of the
virus
causes more severe illness and there is
no evidence at this stage
to suggest that the new strain will
affect the effectiveness of the vaccines
that are being developed or indeed the
vaccine that is currently
in use in scotland and all of that is
reassuring
although further analysis is underway
however there is strong evidence now
that
the new strain is spreading
substantially and significantly more
quickly
than the strains of the virus that we
have been dealing with up to now
and that evidence suggests that it could
be up to
70 percent more transmissible than
previous strains of the virus and it may
increase
the r number by up to 0.4
now it is believed that this faster
transmission
may be driving the rapidly deteriorating
situation
in the south of england including london
and in wales where we already see cases
rising quickly and hospitals under very
severe
and growing pressure now we do not yet
know
how widely this new strain of the virus
is circulating
in scotland the latest information is
that
17 cases have been identified in
scotland
through genomic sequencing but i think
we have to be
realistic that that is likely to be an
understatement of its true prevalence
right now so all of that
tells us that the strain albeit that it
may still be at lower levels than in
some other parts of the uk
is present here already in scotland and
therefore it does
pose a real risk to us if we do not act
and act firmly
and while further analysis is required
to establish this
one way or another we do already have a
concern that this strain
may be driving what appears to us
already
to be faster transmission of covid in
some
hospitals and also in some care homes
so given that this strain is circulating
we know widely already in some parts of
the uk
and given that we know it is already
seeded in scotland
and is already circulating albeit
perhaps at a lower level in scotland
the bottom line we face right now is
this if we don't act
firmly and decisively now to stop it
transmitting
it will take hold here and if that
happens the very
serious and the rapidly worsening
situation that we see
unfolding now in wales in london and in
the south east of england
will develop here too and that would
mean many more people getting
covered in the weeks ahead and it would
mean that by
january our nhs could potentially be
overwhelmed which of course we have
managed to avoid at every stage so far
of the pandemic
and if all of that happened it would
mean many
more people dying from this virus than
would otherwise be the case
now to those who will understandably
look at our case levels right now in
scotland and say
this action is not justified because our
current case
levels are relatively low i would say
this
four weeks ago london's cases were very
low
too and now they are running out of
control
and that is what we face unfortunately
if in the face of this
very severe warning we have been giving
today we do nothing
and that is why the cabinet has decided
today that further
action is necessary and that that action
requires to be firm
it is true to say that this action is
not solely
in response to the severity of our
current situation nor even is it simply
a worry about greater interaction over
the christmas period in and of itself
it is very firmly action designed to
prevent things getting worse potentially
very quickly getting worse as a result
of this new strain
and i know that accepting greater
restrictions on this basis not as a
result of what is happening in the here
and now but to stop a situation
deteriorating
is hard for people to accept i really
understand that
but the most important thing we have
learned through this pandemic
is that failing to act quickly
decisively and preventatively in the
face of this virus
is always a mistake if i could have my
time all over again
i would act more quickly in february and
in early march
and it's important that we do take the
warning we are being given now
very seriously and make sure our actions
are appropriate in the face of that
so my judgment is if we do nothing now
or do too little now knowing what we
now know about this new strain things
will get worse and be much worse than
they need to be
but if we do act now we have a chance of
keeping the situation under control
while the vaccination program continues
to make progress and get case numbers
back
to very low levels again so that's why
we have decided to act
and to act firmly now the action we
propose and i'm about to set out is
designed to do two things and both of
these things
are important firstly the action is
designed to prevent
more of this new strain entering
scotland from parts of the uk where we
know
it is already circulating more widely
and second given that we know it is
already present in scotland albeit we
think
in lower numbers right now this action
is designed to reduce the risk of it
spreading
any further here within scotland so let
me
set out what the cabinet has decided
firstly we are asking everyone to
redouble
your personal efforts in sticking to the
rules
and following facts that may sound
obvious but it is really important that
means staying
out of each other's houses it means
abiding
by travel restrictions it means keeping
a safe distance from people in other
households
and it means following all of the
hygiene advice really
really strictly if you have been letting
your guard
down which given what we have all lived
under now for so long might be
understandable please lift your guard
again
it is as important now as it was back in
february and march that we follow
all of that advice very very strictly
secondly in order to reduce the risk of
more of this strain being imported into
scotland we intend to maintain
a strict travel ban between scotland and
the rest of the uk
unfortunately and i am genuinely sorry
about this
that ban will remain in place right
throughout the festive period
we simply cannot risk more of this new
strain entering the country
if we can possibly avoid it that means
people from scotland not
visiting other parts of the uk and vice
versa across
border travel for all but the most
essential purposes
is not permitted we're also asking
police scotland and
transport operators to consider how the
enforcement of this
can be strengthened in the period ahead
though of course how that
is done is an operational matter for the
chief constable
we'll also be reviewing urgently over
the next day or so the position on
international travel and i will update
on that early next week but in the
meantime
my strong advice continues to be against
non-essential
foreign travel thirdly we have already
advised that we're possible people
should celebrate christmas
at home in their own household and meet
with others
outdoors only the five-day flexibility
from the 23rd to the 27th
of december was planned to recognize the
impact of loneliness and
the difficulty i know we all feel in
leaving loved ones
alone over christmas however earlier
this week we
advised that people should meet indoors
with other households if
at all on no more than one day over the
five day period
given the concern we now have about this
new strain we
now intend to change the law to allow
indoor at mixing in a bubble on
christmas day
only from midnight or a minute past
midnight on christmas day to
midnight going into boxing day
in large parts of england as the prime
minister has just
announced that will not even be allowed
we will allow christmas day to go ahead
but as we have said from the start only
use this flexibility if you really
truly need to this new strain
makes that message all the more
important our advice is still
not to meet indoors even on christmas
day with other households
if you can possibly avoid it if you have
people traveling to join you for
christmas from elsewhere in the uk that
will no longer
be permitted equally it will no longer
be permitted
uh for any of us to travel to anywhere
in the rest of the uk for christmas
and we simply cannot take the risk of
this strain
traveling from different parts of the uk
if you decide to travel within scotland
that will be allowed on christmas day
only if you can't make it there and back
on the same day please don't go
and we're asking you not even to do that
unless
you feel there is genuinely no
alternative finally on christmas day the
household limits will still apply
as we had set out for the five day
period a maximum of eight people from
three households will be the law
but again our advice will be to minimise
those numbers as much as possible
standing here saying this um
actually it makes me want to cry as i'm
sure listening to it will make many of
you want to cry
because i know how harsh this sounds um
i know how unfair it is
but this virus is unfair it doesn't care
about christmas it doesn't care about
anything other than spreading itself
as far and wide as possible and it has
just become
unfortunately a lot better at doing that
now one other point i want to make if
you have caring responsibilities
you can as has always been the case
still visit somebody else and travel
to do that on any day if it is essential
to provide care or assistance to a
vulnerable person that
will not change but for everyone else my
message is please
stay home and stay safe this christmas
that is
in your own interest and in the
interests of everybody you love
now beyond christmas because of this new
strain we also
need to make some changes and this is my
fourth point
today to limit as far as we can the risk
of this strain spreading further
than it has within scotland we intend to
apply
level four measures to all of mainland
scotland
for a period of three weeks from one
minute after midnight on boxing day
morning the exceptions to that will be
orkney shetland and the western isles
and the other island communities where
we have
reduced restrictions in recent weeks
these areas will go to level three
with strict restrictions on who can
travel to and from them
all of these levels will be reviewed
after two weeks
to be clear that means that from boxing
day morning so this includes boxing day
non-essential shops will close as well
pubs cafes and restaurants takeaway food
will
continue to be allowed finally
since the summer we have been determined
to keep schools open and that remains
our determination as far as we possibly
can
and we've asked people adults to bear a
greater burden of restrictions so that
we can
afford to keep pupils in our classrooms
the situation
of this new strain though means that
until we are sure we have that firmly
under control until we are
sure that we are not facing the same
situation as in the south of england or
wales
we must slightly change our plans for
how schools will operate
after the christmas period schools will
still open next week
and will close on schedule as previously
planned we are not
changing that they were then due to
reopen from the 5th of january with all
council areas back by the 7th of january
instead of that here is what we are now
going to do for the children of key
workers
nurses in our hospitals for example
schools will open and stay open as
previously scheduled
they will also open as normal for the
most vulnerable children
all teachers will also return to work as
scheduled
and as planned however for the majority
of pupils
the holiday period will be extended
until the 11th of january
and starting on that date learning will
be online until at least the 18th
of january after that assuming we are
confident we have the virus under
control
we will aim to reopen schools at fully
but at least until the 18th of january
schools will go online only
other than for the children of key
workers and the most vulnerable
thank you for bearing with me i'm going
to ask the chief medical officer and the
national clinical director to say a word
or two
after me but i've taken a bit of time to
set
all of this out because i know how
difficult this is and that's
where i want to conclude i know this is
difficult because it's christmas
i know it's difficult because it is
involving greater restrictions for a
period after christmas
and i know it's also difficult because
right now as of now
our case numbers look as if they are not
as bad as elsewhere
and therefore i understand that people
will be thinking is this necessary
please believe me when i tell you with
every fiber of my being i would not be
standing here
on the saturday before christmas
announcing this if i did not think this
was
necessary i have spent as all of you
have many
anxious and worried days over the course
of the past 10 months
but i've really felt more worried
since much earlier in the year as i have
today if we don't act now firmly and
decisively this new strain is
transmitting so quickly
that it will very quickly overwhelm us i
want to do
everything i can to reduce that
possibility
and that is why these very difficult but
very necessary measures are being
outlined today
i briefed the leaders of the opposition
parties earlier on i will set out
to parliament as as and when the
presiding officer thinks that
it is necessary but i didn't want uh to
leave any time before setting out to you
the public
at what these plans are particularly
given the proximity to christmas
i know how difficult a christmas this is
was always going to be
but now in particular it will be even
more difficult i am genuinely sorry
about that but we must take care
collectively to stop this virus
overwhelming
us to keep ourselves and our loved ones
stay safe and stop people
dying unnecessarily and therefore i ask
you
to bear with us as we try to navigate
our way through
this next difficult stage of this
pandemic
my final point is this i've said a
couple of times in recent weeks that
there is a light
in fact i've said many times in recent
weeks that there is a light at the end
of the tunnel
there is a light at the end of the
tunnel it has not gone out
the vaccination program will pick up
pace as we go into
january but i've also said that there
will be times because we are still in
this pandemic
where the light will be difficult to see
that's the stage we're at right now we
can't see the light at the moment it's
obscured
because of this difficult phase but it
hasn't gone out
it is still there we do have brighter
times ahead
but in order to get us safely or as
safely as possible to those brighter
times
i need to ask you for more sacrifices
for a period
thank you so much for listening the
chief medical officer is going to say a
few words
then the national clinical director and
then we are going to take some questions
from journalists
as normal